[Music]
I'm a regular guy that got caught up in
extraordinary circumstances
this story is as accurate as it is
unbelievable
couldn't make this up it happened to me
Paul is this what happened it's all been
put in the book
I'm a single dad raising my son Johnny I
always brought Johnny with me on my
first dates and I came across a woman
family oriented stay-at-home mom Audrey
[Music]
he's the main guy he's gonna play
himself guilty has charged your honor
wow that's weird action shortly after we
were married she was trying to fleece
Paul out of money what'd you do I'm
getting a psychic reading I'm Terry J
I'm a pet psychic I'm sensing that this
is bigger than we think what I said that
that started the discoveries holy
of her secret double life she had a
secret phone and she had secret
addresses this is the spot this woman
must be stopped
I went and paid a visit to the FBI this
story every time you turn over a rock
I'm the warrior now you'll find several
more Pebbles Goosebumps I'm in full
stealth mode this case haunts me it
started off here and it just went here
[Music]
Scotty I'm in the Twilight Zone
no no no this is the script now don't
worry it'll be great
foreign
[Music]